et mike horn sans rire à chaque fois t
gdi la fois j'ai dit que dans l'émission
jeudi m'énerve dans ces rôles où est il
à tous les prix je suis là il n'a rien
des sceaux dont il est bon et les beaux
gosses in aventurier il peut faire des
merguez avec de ddd silex mon frère tu
as tu le mets dans le désert mon frère
et puis du couscous avec du sable et du
clip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu sais moi moi je t'aime
maintenant franchement je t'aime mais
c'est vrai que tu es que tu sais que tu
es le cauchemar de tous les hommes
pourquoi non mais si on se dit tu
imagines tu là je suis jamais à la
maison mais alors ne mettez pas la
maison frère mais pas que parent je peux
te dire non on préfère te voir loin
après avant l'aventuré
tu te retrouves avec jules à au club med
frères chéquier mort c'est bon car
l'immeuble elle arrive tir à l'arc bin
dans le mille
il avait mis des tampons des sports vous
savez lire ci dessus c'est à dire tout
les matchs et toutes les m'appelle paul
pichon que mike horn derrière toi tu
dois t'on la troisième semaine quand il
sera prêt voilà certainement aller voilà
la tête de ma mère c'est le court -
navires us des beurres celui-là il te
flingue histoire en commun comme son ami
et la main je vais chez le kiné à prix
bas serrer la main la poêle c'est mal je
vais ramener bikeboard
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que et on y est là il est
toujours souriant vous kéké jeu c'est
isabelle vous êtes mouillés et molle un
des grands regrets de ma vie c'est que
je devais faire c'est alain puisqu'il
voulait pas me mener à l'état sauvage
non et que diane lane il fallait être
absent trois semaines
et j'étais ici donc c'était pas possible
mais tata mon numéro de téléphone tu
peux m'appeler
tu sais que quand tu l'appelles sur un
tableau avait tu l'appelles la idea si
tu as pas le bec dans une heure shaw
kilimandjaro là le gars tu sais pas oui
les frères tu la peine c'est pas patiné
en haut d'une montagne n'est dans un
il est sur un train de faire du rafting
mon frère c'est la brique douveneau
monde à la maison en train de manger des
chips
voilà pourquoi il est comme ça et nous
on est comme dire que malgré la série
sans rigoler et j'étais 32 jours à la
maison en cinq ans non tranché mais je
te jure et jessica tu devais ça c'est
beaucoup mais alors mais pas à filer
mais pourquoi tu as la boue des thèmes
pas rester à la maison non mais qu on
est tellement bien ailleurs ouais ouais
bah tu veux quand tu rentres à la maison
ces jeux pour changer les pilot ouais
ouais
josé luis achaco tu rentre chez lui il
est accusé sur mes 10 à la fan de cast a
dit libre et pourquoi ta pâte à vous
tous voulaient pas venir c'est que chez
full c'est des gens aventures de fait
dix ans de télé était toujours vivant ça
c'est la vrai nom tu veux que je te
fasse un aveu je te le jure que c'est
vrai j'avais eu le grand patron de m6
nicolas de tavernost qui est un ami je
lui avais dit franchement je peux
demander à ses 8 pour partir avec mike
horn parce que ça me choquerait il
m'avait dit vas-y demande à ses 8 et
puis c'est vite voilà ils sont dix bah
voilà pourquoi j'ai rien quand même
on devait partir comme un temps qu san
jose 5 jours ça fait une semaine ça fait
une semaine de castaldi en perte sèche
et 2 millions d'euros
bien que mon la chaîne a dit tu fermes
ta gueule tu vas rester ici on a vous
raconte
et puis alors j'ai très peu de vacances
ah ouais mais on va je vous dis tu veux
proposer un truc à mike ladd dans un
instant très cool je suis content que je
suis là j'ai des choses à lui dire à
nike en moi je lui dise droit dans les
yeux je dire ce que je pense à vous de
leur vie vraiment que ça me donne envie
moi partir avec lui tu imagines les deux
là sans portable huawei son portable
aurait fallu non mais on a alors on veut
pas d'obstacle les gens par tous les
deux on va pas non plus mettre des
handicaps
vous seriez vraiment parti sans dire par
exemple je veux aller là et pas dans tel
pays sans exigence en condition est ce
que tu en train de dire là je voudrais
savoir vraiment moi je voulais je vous
dise je suis magoar le mic il me dit tu
vas là je vis là je ferme ma gueule
voilà c'est vrai je voulais toujours
taper tout le monde mais michael
bizarrement là vous êtes moins dans la
faune dans l'affrontement et ben on va
partir ensemble et on va voir qui va
revenir